con la decoración navideña todavía en
las ventanas este pub de londres ha
permanecido casi cuatro meses cerrado
pero este lunes el propietario puede
limpiar las telarañas y dar la
bienvenida a sus ávidos clientes el pap
está completamente reservado esta
primera semana nos gusta estar aquí
disfrutamos una cerveza estar al aire
libre encontrarnos con gente es la
naturaleza humana de momento el servicio
es solo exterior y con dos metros de
separación entre mesas máx máximo son
seis personas por mesa dos núcleos
familiares lujosos
lo que significa que el pap solo puede
llenarse a la mitad de su capacidad y
sin contar con el interior
todos estamos intentando no perder
dinero somos afortunados de tener un
buen espacio exterior
sin embargo no todos los locales tienen
la misma suerte la mayoría de pubs y
restaurantes no podrán abrir hasta el
mes que viene cuando se permita el
servicio en el interior
este lunes por todas partes los
comercios van subiendo las persianas
incluidas las peluquerías que han estado
cerradas desde diciembre la exitosa
campaña de vacunación del reino unido-
permite esperar que el tercer
confinamiento que está llegando a su fin
vaya a ser el último sin embargo el
gobierno pide prudencia a los ciudadanos
y alerta que el riesgo de rebrote se
mantiene